so now let's consider what if you had
some arbitrary power of him ok now we've
been calling this these integrals
capital I so far and one of the reasons
why that's convenient is because lets
you see remember for this problem or
look there's an either to peers against
it is this relationship here it just
makes it algebraically if it's simpler
to do my okay I'll then take advantage
of that same thing again but I'm going
to extend the notation a little bit
because you see how I'm in green you
notice I highlighter but this integral
it's not the same every time but these
clearly are in the same they're like
another family of integrals together
okay so this is kind of like I where the
power is too and this is I'm where the
power is 1 and this is I where the power
is 0 okay so what would you call if I
have the integral of x to the air yes
this is my where the power is in ok so
I'm going to call it I subscript and
because i'm going to have a few
different eyes flying around and i want
to be able to stick tweet them and i
won't actually know what these numbers
are right so i need to label them in
some way ok so just like before and then
we can do this part in our heads because
we've seen it we've just seen it happen
right what are we going to choose for
you and Daniel yet yeah you're all your
so-called early going to point your
exponential here because it ends up with
something just like you had before and
you want to put your polynomial time up
here because it gets progressively
better each time you go through
integration by parts that make sense ok
so therefore this next load I'm going to
have you and be you so we chose you to
be that holiday litter next yes we chose
v we chose DVM DX but because of our
twist there you just ended up with vb e
DX again ok here comes my VDU component
so the integral of now I already know
what V is it's easy x what's d you can
to be yeah so this is this is the result
of just one application differentiation
to whatever I chose as you write so be
over here i'm going to have and X to the
N minus 1 that would be differentiating
ones yea DX how does it heavy feel that
make sense okay now have a look at this
reason for a second let's just tidy it
up just like I did before I have a
concert which I don't need to actually
have insight into it and pull it out so
I've got my ex and in the X take away
add lots of what now I am trying to find
just like I did before what's the
connection to the earlier integral that
I started with this guy right now if I
just put the turds in the right order if
I might mask halloween or two about the
front just like it was a point of it
from here you can see that this is part
of a family this is in that group of
original integrals that I started with
with one difference the power is no
longer in the power of Zed ones want
everything else is the same I mean well
it's only the EPX there ok so Patton in
this case quite easy to identify i'm
going to write it like this
okay so what is this what you have just
written down uber green this is an
interesting King okay because I want a
sort of looking at from one way it's
like this is a bit awkward looking at la
it's very very powerful what we just
written down is called a recurrence
relation recurrence relation that's a
different mouthful that's entirely for
today as well you want the right one
okay what you've got is a definition for
something some algebraic do this
integral I am right and the wave to find
it the way you've defined this thing is
in terms of a kind of version of itself
right so this is in program text we
cooked a recursive definition right it's
I'm what is I am what if you talk about
I n minus 1 it is i can tell you what my
edges now we saw this all the way back
in series and sequences right you can
come up with recursive definitions or
say successive terms of an AP or
successive terms in a jeep it for
instance maybe you want to write this
off on the side in a different part 1 17
you know it hate me right you can define
the nth phone in terms of the term that
came behind it right if it's an AP
you're going to start with the previous
term and what makes me go from one terms
of the Nexus ap you're just going to add
like the common difference every single
time right so the epitome is the
previous one plus some kind of
difference right and it in GP we can say
the same thing but of course it's not a
common difference anymore it's a common
ratio so you'd say the previous term
multiplied by whatever that ratio is ok
so these are kind of like this right you
see there's how do you get this one just
have a look at the previous one and then
you can tell me ok so you can take
advantage of this anytime you like
because it sort of automates this
process of integration by parts yeah
earlier you know it works in lots of
different contacts ok now just before we
leap off to see different ways at least
away let's just try this with the next
one up okay so this was I to you notice
that powers to write if I asked you to
do I three you'd have to go through this
whole process again what would be one
step up okay but let's see if this will
not make things a little bit easier for
us so i'm going to write x 3 i'm just
going to use this recurrence relation
this definition here you having onto a
single application of integration by
parts you're aware when we went through
here it was the same integration by
parts again it's just the powers that
just drop down earlier okay so that's
watch what happens to you i'm going to
write the first line i'm just going to
substitute IAM 3 ever RCM okay so this
is going to be X huge NEX take away 13
months of I n minus 1 which is three
months one which is to write so you see
that's get there is one its drop the
power down just like here this is i2
equals napping minus 2i one she done
which is about to appear so i've got x
cubed ATX take away three lots on now
just like i did in this slide i'm now
gonna write again or what i 2 i 2 is
this thing with tues everywhere there
are ends right so i'm going to write
that as x squared in e to the X this
should be familiar this was our line
over there and take away one two lots
off i won but x cubed e to the X minus
three x squared e to the X what I 1 I 1
i've got x edx i'll go to find one more
step down right take away two locks off
this is I n so I one will be X to the
one near the X take away 11 lot of I 0
okay now i will come back to this I 0 of
it in a minute of love a minute or maybe
a lesson or two because when you have a
look at the way you define this
depending on what your original integral
ears sometimes there's no such thing as
I 0 right it's like maybe your end up
dividing by 0 or something like that
depending on what kind of original
integral you begin with but in this case
I 0 it makes sense it has a definition
its well defined what is i0 actually
already have another one yeah there's I
see we actually wrote this right look oh
there's a power of 0 and a perigee just
means it's x 1 so therefore at this
point i can say x cubed e to the X minus
3 minus 2 minus 1 but I 0 it's just
going to be even X this is the last
integral so I'm going to bring my
cluster in there as we know it does
matter where the closet is so just have
a look at that right now i can now i
just like i did before take out a common
factor of 3x because it happens every
time and they just watch for your signs
here the first one I've got is an
executor how many DX is do I have here
minus 3x square how many edx's do I have
here I've got plus 6 times X by the way
an easy way to later on the right track
is because you can see my powers coming
down from each successive application of
intervention methods and then I've got
one last one right minus three x minus 2
is plus six x minus one plus constant
okay so you can see here having done a
single application of integration by
parts being that all I'm really doing is
doing over and over and over again I've
incorporated a bill of rule a recurrence
relation out of my first application of
integration by parts and then once I had
that rule I can just use that rule
multiple times to climb down the ladder
as it were and get down to something
which just gets evaluated which is find
the one
case does that make sense yeah okay now
this is the simple examples the simplest
example that I could choose because you
can see that the climbing down very
easily because it's a polynomial but
number one this recurrence relation idea
it's is more versatile than that you can
use it in more than just I is kind of
cool in the EDX stay the same about to
show you example and secondly even
though we've seen recurrence relations
are built with began look at them
through integration by parts you can
actually develop recurrence relations
with that integration by parts we're
going to get to that soon okay so this
idea here of getting an integral in
terms of like a smaller version of
itself that's what this is about